[Musique]
masques singer le grand champ de tf1
n'arrête pas de perdre des
téléspectateurs d'une semaine à l'autre
il faut dire que chaque émission est
accompagné de sa petite déception niveau
casting et surtout le jury perd en
crédibilité avec des propositions de
plus en plus improbable pronostic final
à vous les enquêteurs pour l'hippocampe
alessandra sublet partait sur la célèbre
actrice audrey tautou quoi à d'audrey
tautou mais plutôt pour le monstre jarry
paris est quant à lui sur la star de
l'humour de france à jamel debbouze est
encore une fois pas de djamel mais
plutôt bons résultats le jury ne des
masques pas grand monde
il paraît même parfois un peu ridicule
mais on a appris que les grands quêteurs
serait fortement influencé par la
production qui leur souffleraient ses
idées dans l'oreillette
on note également qu'à chaque révélation
camille combal nous donne directement le
cv de la personnalité au cas où on
l'aurait pas reconnu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas là où le jury fait le
boulot en revanche c'est dans son rôle
d'acteur il joue à merveille les
enquêteurs impressionné et surpris
[Applaudissements]
il reste quelques stars sous les masques
un pronostic s'il vous plaît c'est
jérôme commandeur big flo et oli ça pour
être christian tu l'as dit après tout
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes sûrs alors après avoir vu tout
ça selon vous les missions décridibilise
tel le jury vraiment je vous dis depuis
le début je déteste cette émission à me
fout le bourbon vous dit ça me rappelle
un vieux spectacle de chantal goya et
j'adorais chantal goya mme géraud
l'impression d'avoir quatre ans je suis
en angoisse de ouf
mais pour moi c'est pas la faute du jury
si l'émission est pourri c'est la faute
de tf1
si vous voulez moi si vous me donnez un
gros chèque et que vous me dites de dire
que l'église pas le jury qui propose
certainement à la fin ça les rend pas
très crédible mais moi si je regarde
l'émission jeudi les pauvres ils sont
payés on leur demande de faire ça moi si
vous me demandez toute la journée quand
je vois bernard montiel de dia mais
c'est johnny hallyday je le ferais autre
angle il est excellent parce que c'est
ça et le jury le jury dit n'importe quoi
parce qu'effectivement il ya des
oreillettes
imaginez un seul instant que le jury
trouve parce qu'ils sont quand même pas
idiots qui trouve les gens qui sont sous
les costumes
l'émission avait fini donc évidemment la
production leur zee de dire n'importe
quoi
ils ont l'air ridicule et continue de
s'amuser et du coup ils en font trop
c'est de l'outrance et franchement vous
avez tout à fait raison
ça va pas tenir très longtemps le mentor
de base parce que peut-être que je
savais qu'il y aurait les costumes comme
camille combal on voit bien que les
services qui sont des palmarès comme ça
des gens que ça dommage parce que du
coup c'est un peu décevant jusqu'en mai
le jury fut d'accord ça il tourne même
pas besoin de l'aide de tf1 pour se
crédibiliser c'est une catastrophe avait
tout seul mais voir juste reparler bah
oui mais quand on entend qu eva adams
qui dit assure yves lecoq
merci monsieur d'être venu saluer le
grand moment de solitude même lui qui
est pas non plus un petit je ne sais
même pas qui y est yves lecoq et
j'aimerais qu'on revienne aussi si vous
voulez bien sûr camille combal de
petites minutes parce que je vous trouve
très gentil avec lui alors qu'il serait
franchement à l'ordre par rapport à ce
qu'il a à faire
déjà s'imaginer quatre personnes ici il
sera invité dans ce genre d'émission
alors dit ray faire partie d'un jury
avec des stars à découvrir
et tout d'un coup puisque la réalité on
dit aujourd'hui que ces gens ne seraient
pas qui se cache derrière les costards
il arrive et tout d'un coup elle a redit
ce et smaïn ces machins alors qu'eux ils
sont venus dans ce jury sans toucher de
l'argent pour essayer de découvrir des
stars vous souvenez de la bande annonce
de l'émission c'est survendu au départ
elle a été surpayés aïssi million et
demi c'était sûr pays en terme de score
et bien évidemment il ya eu un effet
déceptif énorme mais était d'après
salade escorte pour tf1 qui sont
convenables je vais faire une saison 2
mais la france ont fait revivre avec des
rivières d'écouté mois avec des rimes il
dérive et où il n'ya pas le public où il
a en fait finalement même pas la
personne qui a il a un fond vert
c'est un miracle si vous avez vendu
merci de reconnaître les stars grâce à
leur voix
et vous avez vous déjà entendu parler
marie josé pérec connaissez comment je
suis moi moi j'aurais pas reconnu par
exemple
un scoop
[Musique]
mais j'aime ça j'aime donner des scoops
et missions non
il paraît qu'il ya une deuxième je parle
au conditionnel qui est déjà programmée
au printemps dont vous dites tous des
bêtises vous êtes à côté de la plaque
dorée la deuxième avait déjà fait qu'ali
des stars problème ça peut être nourri
non ce que ça peut être il y aura pour
vous d'une saison brillante 6e à 6
heures
c'est
a quand même avoué dans une interview
qu'effectivement on leur aurait donc oui
ça les met en danger etc des grands
nombres je trouve que c'est un très beau
jury et que c'est dommage de les faire
passer très dangereux à vue des saisons
écoutez on va affaire à suivre